we sent you to london we sent you to
london yes
and and uh to cover the fast
and furious six premiere and you know
cause i just felt i gotta cover that
premiere
[Laughter]
i really did this was me this was no tie
at all to the movie company we in no way
benefited i just said
i need someone to cover the fast and
furious six premiere
i said get me pete holmes and i actually
did this with my finger i said get him
when you called i picked up the phone
and said uh you want me to cover fast
six isn't that it yeah i knew
immediately
yeah you've even uh you've even
shortened that to fast six
that's what it is it's fast sex with
donny jeans
uh you shorten everything i can't help
but i call you cones these are breezies
is anyone else longer that is longer are
you like elongated
uh but how was it how was it over there
in in london what i love about london
is you know they've mastered the english
language they've mastered i know i know
it's theirs
it's theirs yeah we've ruined it but
we've taken something away we've lost
something
what they do in conversations i think
americans could learn is they always
bounce things back
you're having an awkward conversation a
british person will always bounce it
back because they know
nobody really cares what you have to say
they just want to hear themselves talk
so i think we could learn this i i don't
know i i'm not sure i quite understand
what you're saying i'll give you an
example
okay cones these are breezies
somebody comes up to you and they tell
you something that you don't want to
hear that makes it really awkward for
you so
i don't know it's just like uh i i just
don't think my grandma's gonna make it
through the summer or something
really sad and difficult
i'm so sorry what americans do is you
take the ball in your court and you
realize it's your turn to talk so you're
like oh
this is what i do ghost oh no death
right death is a part of life and i'm so
sorry for your upcoming loss
nobody cares hit the ball back that's
what they do in britain that's what they
do someone goes
i think grandma's not going to make it
through the summer she's on the way out
is she
right back you don't want that
it's perfect i'm giving you a gift your
life is better now this is fantastic it
doesn't matter
i wrote some things some situations okay
some things that maybe you could admit
conan okay and i'll show you how to
british it
okay all right so this is me talking and
you're gonna you're gonna talk back to
me as a british person all right show
you how to defuse awkwardness
okay these are all right i'll just read
these i'm seeing them for the first time
i've been wetting the bed every night
for the past 12 years
having a bit of a tinkle problem are you
it's really making me depressed yeah
feeling a bit blue
i might kill myself i might hang myself
painful though in it
[Laughter]
you're right maybe i'll shoot myself
instead
faster yeah jeez
that's the other thing yeah it's a gift
it's a real gift that's fantastic the
word the way they use the word
cheers too is just the perfect what does
that mean it just means the
conversation's over
yes cheers if someone's just like i got
a rash and it's spreading you're like
jeez and you just walk away we have
nothing like that
now we do
you